toi vous démarrez ces éliminations
directes
il y aura un grand vainqueur à la fin un
tony m attention c'est parti on a pas
mal c'est pas possible
attention c'est parti ça devrait
toujours qu'à des sicules la côte est
très dure et que ça le pont quand jamin
ouais bah oui elle va revenir on voit
aussi à toi tranquille et me dire vrai
on attendait avec moi oui il aimait
chanter les gens l'utilisent
on va aller vite vite on me l'a assisté
au pays en ce 4 non mais oh ça va pas
bien aller c'était avant d'être envoyée
ok merci max attention mais c'est
terminé pour les très bons entre
gouvernements tiennent attendu avec les
autres dans la torture
le champion olympique et l'aï aimé
l'imiter
allez on y va il reste gilles isabelle
géraldine qu'a dit tony nom isabelle
éliminés d'ailleurs juste g6 et tony qui
gagne il peut pas enfiler mon maillot et
rentre à l'abandon un site aussi pataude
d'ailleurs attentats temps ça tony sol
dénoncer ce qu'ils ont fait ils sont
celles qui sont trop attention
ils sont plus qu'un obus rangs trois
bâtiments tonnes
machault à les méchants tonnes de
déchets dégoûté attention comme il reste
deux filles deux garçons qui va gagner
oui vite animal et gérald et husser
géraldine tu sers attention on est plus
de 3 kg géraldine ça joue très bien la
belle attention c'est la finale on
enlève le dit ce qui nous plaît alors
entre vous en appoint et après je
rencontre le gagnant et juridictions
qu'est ce qu'il ya de neuf fois autant à
point attention
géraldine c'est qu'elle s'est toujours
te dois géraldine c'est très simple si
vous me battais way en deux points
je vous le dis oui je mettrai le slip de
camping pendant toute l'émission
d'accord on joue bas je choisirais
quelqu'un qui va porter le slip de
camping pendant toute l'émission
d'accord j'ai déjà une petite hip hop
est ce que tu es ce que tu as le style
de camping à poil quand tu l'as sur toi
non non non mais si le pc le vrai
[Applaudissements]
mais attends et quoi tu veux tu peux tu
va l'enlever
bah oui je vais l'enlever et donc la
personne va le mettre sur le vrai le
principe c'est celui de patrick chirac
apporter mon gars bon allez on y va
sereinement c'est ainsi que deux points
est-ce qu'on a chargé une tong magic
ouais c'est ça c'est la maquette
directement un battant il est bien celle
là où c'est bien toi allez c'est parti
et bien attention auxerre en deux points
qui sert c'est comme vous allez honneur
à vous vas-y géante à l'essieu savais
que ça pouvait nul je suis en prison
pas
dans sa joue quoi tu la fermes ans la
règle alors est-ce qu'on fait deux
points d'écart et on les voit minton et
l'autre comme au bâton
attention attention balle de match j'ai
gagné à gauche on tremble déjà
est ce que tu peux me donner le slip
bien sûr si tu vas me donner maintenant
à côté du camping ont fait pas du
contrat doit le script ou si vous avez
rien dessous non mais laisse le saint
géry on laisse une ouverture quelque
chose qu'on va voir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors donc je vais désigné je vais
désillusion lors de la bête
celui qui va porter le slip si à la fin
de l'émission
je vais demander l'avis de tony tony you
tube qui sony sony qui tu veux tu as ta
mamie descoings ouais ouais je sais mais
[Applaudissements]
benjamin castaldi
tu vas te préparer mon chéri thuriau
dans l'instant